new at six Nevada Democratic senator
Catherine Cortez masto proposing a law
to investigate high gas prices now the
average right now for a gallon of
regular just under four dollars way
lower than the peak of almost six
dollars Cortez masto says her proposal
gives the government tools to look into
if oil companies took advantage of
consumers through price gouging
you just what the evidence tells me and
the facts so far is that big oils made
record profits in the last couple of
years
we also and I also know from that
hearing from energy and natural
resources when I was questioning Big Oil
that they are sitting on over 9000
permits that they didn't even drill used
for drilling to put more Supply in our
supply chain to help lower those costs
the senator made a similar proposal in
the last Congress and Republicans would
have to sign on for this to become law